von nahem betrachtet und bei lichte
besehen so sagen die leute heute besteht
unser politisches führungspersonal doch
auch ziemlich schwachen figuren kein
vergleich jedenfalls etwa mit legendären
saft wurzeln wie einst françois
mitterrand diesem demokratischen
monarchen der einst eigenhändig versucht
hat in frankreich den sozialismus
einzuführen
doch war die politik damals wirklich
potenter wenn einer das wissen muss dann
ist es ja katali der einst als haus
vermied er als wichtigster mann im
hintergrund zusammen mit frankreichs
präsidenten ins räderwerk der geschichte
kriegt doch der mann der mitte rangs
wichtigste einflüsterer war und noch
heute zu den spannendsten köpfen
frankreichs zählt er hat sehr klare
vorstellungen davon welchen weg die
grande nation und der rest der welt
einschlagen müssen sollen sie nicht in
gefährliche abgründe stürzen
jacada de jacques attali von welchem
staat welchem frankreich träumten sie im
mai 81 als mitterrand an die macht kam
danke für ihre vorstellung aber ich
betrachte mich eher als universellen
intellektuellen der zufall ich mich in
frankreich zur welt kommen darauf bin
ich stolz in der zufall hat mir
ermöglicht meinen beitrag zum
politischen leben meines landes zu
leisten
aber eben vor allem intellektuelle
schriftsteller professor einer der sich
in der ganzen welt zu hause
er versucht die welt zu denken und nicht
auf frankreich
sie waren immerhin der berater des
präsidenten
das war nur die eine seite als ich
berufen wurde hatte ich bereits 15
bücher publiziert 65 sind es bis heute
und sogar im élysée sah ich die
beratertätigkeit nur als einen teil
meines lebens
sie galten schon damals als
intellektueller der die mächtigen bereit
gewiss ich lese eine kandidatur für die
legislative ab auch angebote für
ministerposten
ich wollte meine intellektuelle freiheit
für eine intellektuelle muss es
verlockend sein gleichzeitig abkürzung
sein wenn auch im hintergrund diesem
hintergrund hält sich freiwillig um
weiterhin schreiben zu können
und ich habe während meiner zeit im
élysée viele bücher publiziert darunter
eines über das leben von sieg mit
warburg
das ist weitgehend in deutschland
abspielt aber auch theoretischen bücher
aber um auf ihre frage zu 1981 zurück zu
kommen
1981 glaubte ich dass er ein
historischer augenblick für frankreich
und ich glaube es bis heute
in frankreich war 27 128 jahre lang von
der rechten regiert worden und ein
machtwechsel wie sich als möglich es
gibt keine demokratie ohne machtwechsel
also musste er gelingen er geschah unter
sehr komplexen intellektuellen
bedingungen denn um diese wahl zu
gewinnen brauchen wir sie sagen wir sie
meinen die linke ja sind sie doch immer
links gewiss auch wenn sich die
definition dieser konzepte sehr
gewandelt hat davon vielleicht später
aber wenn ich etwas binäres wählen muss
dann ist es das doch es gibt heute dinge
das zeigt sich in deutschland die sich
eindeutig auftrag und die eine nation
einmütig anpacken muss mir etwa heute in
frankreich die debatte über die
nationale sicherheit
nach diesen schrecklichen attacken auf
charlie hebdo mit großem markt genau
der frühere präsident sarkozy hatte mich
gebeten eine überparteiliche
reformkommission zu leiten und wer kam
einstimmig auf 300 reformvorschläge in
anderen kommission in welcher sowohl die
linke als auch die rechte vertreten
waren
es gibt also eine gemeinsame
schnittmenge von dingen die eindeutig
getan werden müssten die aber weder von
den linken noch von den rechten
politikern angegangen werden weil sie
den mut nicht haben oder weil es so
schwierig ist es wildermuth vielleicht
reden wir noch davon
ich respektiere die politiker sie sind
die gewählten und ich muss respektieren
dass sie beschließen
aber sind sie schwach wie in der
einleitung sagte die welt hat sich seit
1981 sehr verändert damals hatten die
politischen instanzen schlinger einfluss
auf das reale geschehen weil viel mehr
dinge staatsangelegenheit waren was hat
sich seit damals geändert
die sowjetunion ist verschwunden der
markt hat sich globalisiert und was uns
europäer betrifft die europäischen
institutionen haben sich ausgebreitet
nehmen sie das beispiel frankreich
der präsident der französischen republik
hat gegenüber 1980 enorm viel macht
verloren
es gibt keine todesstrafe mehr zum glück
er hat praktisch keine militärische
macht mehr im sinne einer atomaren
verfügungsgewalt zum glück besteht ja
die nukleare bedrohung nicht mehr
er befiehlt doch über die französische
armee ja aber diese allmächtige auf den
knopf drücken können hat seinen sinn
verloren
zum glück um 1980 zur zeit der
sowjetunion war die atomare gefahr noch
äußerst präsent trug präsident
mitterrand das berühmte café mit ja wie
auch der heutige präsident
aber damals war die nukleare frage von
strategischer bedeutung
der präsident hat seit der einführung
des euro auch die macht über das geld
verloren
er hat viel macht auf dem gebiet der
investitionen eingebüßt weil vieles
dezentralisiert wurde
die globalisierung hat viele unternehmen
verschoben die menschen sind mobil
das gilt für frankreich wie für die welt
der große kampf von heute
unsere diskussion in politischer
hinsicht vielleicht auf den punkt bringt
ist folge der westen hat und die welt
wird ja immer westlicher die
individuelle freiheit als höchsten wert
gewählt und auch wenn der westen sich im
relativen niedergang befindet beherrscht
er durch seine werte doch mehren
so wurden ja auch während das römische
reich zerfiel alle zurück jene die die
römer ersetzten oft sagt man das
gegenteil es ist asien das zurückkommt
im gegenteil
asien wird westlich schauen sie wie man
sich kleidet es kommt mit unseren werten
zurück genau wie die vandalen die man zu
unrecht bahn nannte als sie das römische
reich eroberten wurden sie römer der
religion der römer der sprache der römer
der kleidung
ich verstehe dich ganz allem in china
das wirtschaftlich sehr wichtig geworden
ist gibt es wenig individuelle freiheit
das konnten es gibt eine entwicklung in
diese richtung
wenn sie in die hintersten winkel chinas
reichen wird man mit ihnen über deutsche
oder französische fußballer reden wollen
sie kennen sich aus und die politische
freiheit freiheit kommt nach und nach
man kann nicht von china verlangen in 30
jahren den weg zu gehen für den der
westen zwei jahrhunderte gebraucht hat
das kommt und vergessen sie nicht dass
ich ihnen nur eines der wichtigen länder
ist sogar weniger wichtig als man glaubt
die große demokratie der welt ist indien
mit einer noch größeren bevölkerung
indien wird einen größeren einfluss auf
die welt kam aus china
der rest der welt entwickelt sich in die
gleiche richtung mit einigen ausnahmen
von denen der terrorismus zeugt doch das
sind nur rückzugsgefecht die welt wird
westlich weil wir die individuelle
freiheit zum höchsten werte haben es
hätte andere gegeben man hätte die
solidarität wählen könnte die
unsterblichkeit die brüderlichkeit worte
freiheit geht zu lasten der solidarität
absolut wir haben einen weltmarkt
aufgebaut und dies ohne dafür
universelle regeln aufzustellen
die rechtsnormen sind lokal geblieben
und der markt ist universell geworden
natürlich haben dadurch jene welche in
der politik die regeln aufstellen enorm
viel macht verloren die über jenen die
den markt beherrschen nämlich die
unternehmen die politiker stehen daneben
mit ihrer fiktion
ich komme kurz zurück auf china sie
sagen dass die welt westlicher wird aber
eines der großen probleme in china ist
auch das fehlen eines rechtsstaats der
diesen namen verdient
gewiss aber sie sind ungeduldig
betrachten sie doch die geschichte china
hat seine entwicklung hin zu einer
marktwirtschaft vor 30 jahren da lässt
sich exakt die these anwenden dänemark
großbritannien entworfen hatte und die
sich dann für die ganze welt als richtig
erwiesen
marx hat er erklärt ein starker staat
schafft einer marktwirtschaft in dieser
schafft eine bourgeoisie und diese
wiederum eine mittelklasse
letztere braucht ein recht auf eigentum
und damit auch die demokratie die
demokratie bricht die allmacht des
staates der selbst in bedingungen für
die eigene niederlage geschaffen hat
indem er die marktwirtschaft schuf das
hat mit rohware in england angefangen
und wiederholte sich auf der ganzen welt
und das passiert in china wie schnell in
einem jahrzehnt das ist in frankreich
passiert der lateinamerika geballt wie
lange wird es in china dauern es wird
dort mächtige erschütterungen geben
china könnte auseinanderbrechen denn das
war ja nicht immer ein 1 1 statt
die forderung nach individueller
freiheit hat absolute priorität
das hat natürlich auch seine folgen wer
individuelle freiheit sagt man in erster
linie die bewegungsfreiheit die
demokratie unterscheidet sie von der
diktatur durch das recht auszureisen
die stadt uhren wurden auf
charakterisiert durch die benennung
jener die nicht ausreisen durften die
boatpeople aus vietnam ihre usenix aus
der sowjetunion wie bei servus aus kuba
heute können alle von überall aus reisen
das letzte land aus dem man nicht
ausreisen kann ist nordkorea die
weltbevölkerung ist in bewegung
heute sind wir siebeneinhalb milliarden
bald werden es neun milliarden sein
zurzeit leben 200 millionen außerhalb
des landes in dem sie geboren wurden
in 30 jahren werden es wohl anderthalb
milliarden sein das ruft feindliche
reaktion hervor wie die referenten der
schweiz oder abschottungen wie ende des
und anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
und die entwicklung ist nicht
aufzuhalten
sie ist ihrer siebel wir befinden uns im
übergang von einem zeitalter der
sesshaftigkeit in ein neues logo
wir müssen uns wieder die werte des
nomadentum vergegenwärtigen welche zu
den großen historischen werten der
menschheit gehören
um zu verstehen was auf uns zukommt um
noch einen augenblick bei der frage zu
bleiben
ob die politischer schwachsinn ob unser
politisches personal genügend
qualifiziert ist diese tendenz zum
individualismus zu lasten des
präsidenten
sie geht zu lasten des kollektivs und
das hat zweierlei folgen die erste der
präsident von frankreich oder den usa
besitzt war charisma macht und eine
außergewöhnliche intelligenz ohne dass
ich in personenkult verfallen will obama
ist ein außergewöhnlicher mensch unser
land hat bewundernswerte eigenschaften
von intelligenz ehrlichkeit und fleiß
aber dennoch haben sie weniger macht
obama ist dauernd im clinch mit seinem
parlament seine position ist sehr
schwach nehmen sie die amerikanischen
firmen wir haben nichts mehr am hut mit
amerikanischen interessen
sie interessieren sich für die welt und
erst dann für amerika und frankreichs
präsident selbst wenn du heute general
de gaulle oder françois mitterrand ist
er hätte viel weniger aber waren goal
oder mieten
denn ausnahmepersönlichkeit ja aber noch
einmal das hat viel mit der historischen
situation zu tun
es gibt immer außergewöhnliche menschen
die aber nicht die historische situation
vorgefunden haben um zu kommen es
braucht also günstige bedingungen damit
sich das potenzial entfaltet genau und
in frankreich fand sie françois
mitterrand in so einer situation
er musste nur die bedingungen für den
wechsel schaffen und größere reformen
durchzuführen ist er wie auch sie als
ein wichtigster berater mit einem
utopischen alternativen projekt dann
getreten
topic alternativ wir hatten gleichzeitig
zwei projekte das erste war das gelingen
des wandels in frankreich das heißt form
einzuleiten die einer
sozialdemokratischen vision entsprachen
und das ist gelungen das zweite projekt
sozialdemokratisch nicht sozialistisch
im utopischen sind lassen sie mich dies
noch sagen unser zweites projekt war der
aufbau europas
wenn ein utopischer sozialismus
aufgebaut werden soll kann das für mich
nur ein sozialismus der
unentgeltlichkeit sein und nicht an
sozialismus der knappheit der ware
utopischen sozialismus so wie marx in
übrigens selbst beschreibt ist nicht
eine egalitäre und autoritäre verteilung
der arbeit sondern bedeutet dass man die
bedingungen schafft für eine
gesellschaft des wohlstands und jeder
mensch unentgeltlich zugang zu allen
notwendigen gütern hat und noch genauer
für mich ist eine sozialistische
gesellschaft wo er eine ideale
gesellschaft und dieses wort zu
verwenden eine gesellschaft in der jede
über seine gesamte zeit völlig frei
verfügen
der schlüsselbegriff nachdem ich eine
gesellschaft bewertet zeit der gebrauch
der zeit
welchen teil ihres oder meines lebens
oder all derer die uns zuschauen können
wir absolut frei nutzen
was macht man bei der arbeit hat man
seine arbeit frei gewählt und was es mit
dem privatleben eine gesellschaft ist
umso freier je größer der anteil der
wirklich freien zeit während unserer 60
70 80 oder 100 lebensjahres eine gute
zeit zu schaffen
das ist wesentlich und kann ganz
konkrete dinge bedeutung wenn etwa die
linken das rentenalter möglichst tief
ansetzen wollen und die rechten wollen
dass man halt nichts lange arbeitet so
ist das die falsche debatte was zählt
ist nicht bis zu welchem alter man
arbeitet sondern was man arbeite ich
träume von einer gesellschaft in der
nicht nur sie und ich dir interessante
berufe haben sondern alle in einen beruf
eingespannt sind für eine längere
arbeitszeit demonstrieren würden
weil ihnen ihre arbeit gefällt und sie
weiterarbeiten wollen ich träume von
einer gesellschaft in der man eine
verlängerung der arbeitszeit fordert
weil die arbeitszeit kreativ und für
alle beglückend wäre faszinierend aber
in die richtung läuft ja gerade nicht
nun es gibt auch vieles das in die
richtige richtung läuft
ich erzähle ihnen etwas was
vordergründig nichts mit diesem thema zu
tun hat was aber für mich eine
offenbarung war es wird zu überraschen
ich will ihnen damit zeigen dass nach
meiner vorstellung eine vielzahl von
phänomenen miteinander verknüpft sind
das ferngesteuerte auto offenbar ist der
tag nicht mehr fern da nicht mehr selber
wird den wagen steuern müssen google
silicon valley und so manche sagen das
ist toll und so werden die autos
sicherer aber das ist nicht der punkt
wenn man 22 jahrhundert vom konto des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts reden wird so
wird man sagen
wie konnten die leute so blöd sein
täglich 23 stunden des lebens damit zu
verbringen sich in einem lenkrad
festzuhalten
das ist verlorene zeit wenn das auto
aber fern gewinnen wir gigantischer ein
bis zwei stunden pro tag in echtem leben
irgendwie im wagen sitzen und ein stelle
zu lenken lesen können oder uns
zerstreuen
wer die verarbeiten schwarzen richtig
leben es gibt also das sehen sie an
diesem beispiel aus der technik eine
starke tendenz sich bewusst zu werden
dass die freiheit im freien gebrauch
derzeit besteht das kommt auch in der
technischen entwicklung zum ausdruck
dieser kampf lässt sich also nicht mehr
ins links rechts schema einordnen
wer setzt sich denn für ihre vision ein
die politischen parteien sind daran sich
neu zu orientieren freilich noch einen
sehr unsicheren werden viele konzepte
sind im wandel begriffen galt die welt
von einer einzigen wirtschaft beherrscht
müsste es auch eine umfassende welt
wirtschaftstheorien geben gibt es nicht
noch stehen die wirtschaftstheorien der
länder nebeneinander während die
wirtschaft längst weltumspannend ist es
eine weltwirtschaft theorie würde man
verstehen dass die welt in abwesenheit
eines welt staates zwangsläufig in die
deflation gerät das in die tat um
nehmen sie ein beliebiges land
fernseh den start aller regel berge das
gesetz dann haben sie die depression die
illegale und die kriminelle wirtschaft
genau dies geschieht auf weltebene wir
haben keine welt theorie die politischen
parteien verharren in ihren extrem
anachronistischen werden die werte für
die wir heute 1 stehen müssen sind der
gute gebrauch der zeit hier und jetzt
und auch für die künftigen generationen
wenn es eine kluft zwischen links und
rechts gibt dann ist das für mich die
kluft zwischen denen welche die gute
zeiten für jene wollen welche die
natürliche freiheit besitzen nämlich die
reichen und jenen welche die bedingungen
für die gute zeit schaffen wollen auch
zugunsten jener die keine oder noch
keine stimme haben nämlich die kommenden
generationen die linke wenn man so will
das sind heute jene welche die
bedingungen für die gute zeit schaffen
wollen zugunsten der schwächsten die
keine stimme haben
wer es nicht doch wünschenswert starke
politische persönlichkeiten zu haben die
für das neue paradigma einstehen und den
menschen erklären dass man andere dinge
hand streben soll ja ganz bestimmt
das versuche ich nun zustande zu bringen
mit einer ansehnlichen scharfen freunden
in dem was wir die bewegung für eine
positive wirtschaft
das ist bereits eine weltweite bewegung
für zellen intellektuell und laut
menschen welchem interesse der kommenden
generation arbeit gelehrte vor allem
nicht nur es sind auch wirtschaftsführer
dabei politiker leute den diensten der
künftigen generation arbeiten zum
beispiel in bildung und erziehung in der
demografie für die schulden verminderung
für die thema verbesserungen
alle diese leute bilden diese bewegung
in der politiker und intellektuelle mit
einer anderen geisteshaltung tätig sind
sie machen so viele interessante dinge
man fragt sich wie sie die zeit für all
das finden und das ist ja nur die spitze
des eisbergs
und sie finden sogar die zeit um
politiker zu beraten auch den jetzigen
französischen präsidenten es ist so dass
er ein freund es geht doch um die
positive ökonomie ja er hat mich um
einen bericht zum thema gebeten einen
internationalen nichtfranzösischen so
weit wie möglich versuchen nicht dinge
zu machen die über mainland hinaus
nützlich sind
abgesehen von einer arbeit über die
frankophonie ein thema das natürlich
begrenzt ist auf die leute die diese
sprache sprechen
aber wir haben einen bericht über die
zukunft der positiven wirtschaft gemacht
und über das was für ein land positiv
sein könnte und wichtige reform vorsieht
ich nenne zwei davon die auch in der
schweiz oder in deutschland angewendet
werden könnten erstens man sollte und
wirtschaftsunternehmen dafür sorgen dass
die aktionäre ein stimmrecht haben
welches der lebensdauer des titels
entspricht
es ist nicht normal dass jemand gern tag
der generalversammlung im bruchteil
einer sekunde aktionär wird das gleiche
stimmrecht haben soll wie jemand der
seine titel seit 20 jahren besitzt das
treibt die firmen zu bekehren und
selbstmörderischen entscheidungen eine
gute reform wäre also eine koppelung des
stimmrechts an die lebensdauer des und
da präsident roland gesagt ich bin
interessiert und ergreife massnahmen und
er ist auch ein freund sie sind es ja
der ihn gewissermaßen in die politik
eingeführt hat ja ja so ist es
er war mal mitarbeitern ich halte um
1980 herum das glück eine anzahl junger
menschen zusammenzubringen die später
natürlich ihren eigenen weg gegangen
sind
holland war in der tat 1980 mein
mitarbeiter die auch civil and royal
laurent fabius und andere können sie all
die immer noch jederzeit anrufen
nein das ist tun sie sich nun natürlich
aber wir haben andere
kommunikationsmittel
finden sie es ungerecht wenn über einen
präsidenten wir sprechen dann noch von
den attentaten in paris das hat die
situation zwar geändert aber finde sie
es ungerecht wenn über den präsidenten
schlechtgeredet wird seine umfragewerte
war im keller
man hat den präsidenten lächerlich
gemacht
globi nach einem kamel pudding hat man
ihm genannt es gar noch keinen respekt
mehr hat sie das sehr gestört ich fand
das immer sehr ungerecht weil ich ihn
sehr gut kenne
er ist ehrlich und intelligent arbeitet
hart ist vielseitig interessiert er war
überzeugt dass er anerkannt würde das
unglück will dass er unter tragischen
umständen anerkennung findet schade
heute sagt man oft die welt sei flüssig
geworden das heißt dass die ideologien
und ideen sehr in bewegung sein wird
eine popularität die so schnell
gestiegen ist kann leicht ebenso schnell
wieder fallen
sie wären nicht wieder sieg an kann es
jederzeit denn wenn es nicht mehr so
läuft wegen seiner persönlichkeit als
sie mit dem sherpa waren sahen sie all
die anderen die damals mächtig waren
moritz erträgen von irgendwas er sei der
große kommunikator um ein politisches
führungsmann dazu bekommen braucht es
eine günstige ausgangslage eine
geeignete persönlichkeit und glück
roswall und hatte glück
zuerst bei den wahlen dann in der
führung der staatsgeschäfte bedingungen
sie sprechen davon dass eine kandidatin
ausgeschieden war
die heutigen wirtschaftlichen
bedingungen wirken sich auf die
internationale situation aus von der
schwäche des euro und vom billigen erdöl
kann frankreich um auch präsident reagan
zurückzukommen er war ein äußerst
charmanter mensch aber unglaublichen
kommt nicht intelligent doch sehr
intelligent aber keine kompetenz
irgendwelcher art aber hat einen
wahnsinnigen klare und einfache ideen an
die hat lobte seine ideen haben
geschichte gemacht
die schließung der sowjetischen
raketenbasen die senkung der
öffentlichen ausgaben
ich würde nicht sagen dass alle seinen
ideen gut waren
im gegenteil
gleichzeitig hat er glück gehabt in
seiner amtszeit wurde zu einem
triumphalen abschied der amerikanischen
geschichte
was halten sie von margaret thatcher die
ja auch den lauf der geschichte ihres
landes zu verhindern machte
ja ja ganz bestimmt
sie ehrte ein land das am boden lag sie
war wie ronald reagan
sie hatte einfache ideen und sie wollte
nicht von diesen abrücken
sie hörten nicht auf argumente haben sie
oft mit ihr gesprochen ja sehr oft sehr
oft in begleitung von françois
mitterrand
sie war eine frau was mussten sie frau
thatcher erklären oder sie fragen sehr
vieles wir haben verteidigungsfragen
diskutiert abrüstung europa geologische
fragen und vieles andere
sie hatte übrigens vieles gemeinsam mit
angela nahte ach ja ja sie war chemie
ingenieurin äußerst logisch denken hat
kalt sie wollte alles verstehen was sie
nicht verstand war nicht möglich
unannehmbar zitat lieber nichts als
etwas das sie nicht verstand ich glaube
frau merkel ist genau gleich
sie hielt sich also an einfach alles was
ihr geistiges paradigma störte lehnte
sie ab
das würden sie aber nicht von frau
merkel sagen doch das würde und entweder
gelang es frau thatcher ihren standort
durchzusetzen oder sie gab abrupt nach
denn der kompromiss war für sie nicht
denkbar
aber für frau merkel schon angela merkel
hat auch ihre festen gewissheiten etwa
in bezug auf die europäische zentralbank
wo mario draghi eine weitreichende
entscheidung getroffen hat die sie
begrüßen
ich begrüße sie ist bemerkenswert ich
verlange sie seit drei jahren wie viele
andere
ich sage dass man noch weiter gehen muss
indem man eurobonds schafft aber frau
merkel war sehr lange dagegen und als
draghi die entscheidung traf hat sie
nichts mehr gesagt sie haben also
gewisse vorbehalte gegen leute die
einfache ideen haben nein nicht
unbedingt
so jemand kann ja das werden was man
einen staatsmann net ein staatsmann ist
ja ein mensch mit überzeugung
er muss ich auch mal etwas in den kopf
setzen kann das ist wie im privatleben
oder in der wirtschaft um etwas zu
erreichen was man sich beim ersten
schaltern aufgeben auch beim zweiten und
dritten nicht man muss durch
dabei soll man aber einen klaren kopf
und sein denken und handeln überprüfen
und etwas erst durchsetzen wenn man
sicher ist die zwei oder drei
persönlichkeiten die wir erwähnt haben
waren oder sind sehr eigensinnig
francois mitterrand war es auch auf
seine art ergab oft nicht nach zb hatten
wir einen heftigen streits mit den
amerikanern über die abrüstung die
amerikaner träumten davon dass die
sowjetische abrüstung in der
französischen einherginge kurz gesagt
francois mitterrand hielt diesem
ansinnen stand mit einer mentalen stärke
die alle einschüchterungsversuche
abwehrte damit rettete er die
militärische unabhängigkeit frankreichs
bis heute war eher arrogant
er hatte nur die fähigkeit nein zu sagen
zu dem paar dingen die in der politik
gelernt habe gehört die beste art nein
zu sagen ist zu sagen nein
wenn die person mit der sie verhandeln
bei ist dass sie tatsächlich nein gesagt
haben kann man etwas anderem übergehen
geschieht das nicht oft genug
das kommt drauf an wenn man im innersten
überzeugt ist wenn man im ureigensten
betroffen ist in den dingen wie man
vertritt muss man es tun
kommen wir zur aktuellen lage in
frankreich darf man sagen dass sie
damals als junge berater des präsidenten
von einer strahlenden zukunft träumten
und dass sie heute etwas desillusioniert
sind keineswegs und ich danke ihnen für
die frage erlauben sie mir mit einer
karikatur zu antworten
die zehn jahren ist frankreich das
größte land europas und die in zehn
jahren in zehn jahren ich glaube ohne es
zu ihm schwebt man den niedergang
deutschland ist nicht im interesse
frankreichs und nicht im interesse
europas deutschland absteigen zu sehen
objektiv wie könnte das geschehen
deutschland ist doch das starke das
reiche land keineswegs stark
es ist ein reiches land das aber mehrere
bedeutende schwächen aufweist die erste
ist sicher seine demografische schwäche
deutschland begeht demografischen suizid
in den nächsten 20 jahren werden sich
die dinge schwerlich ändern lassen
in 20 jahren wird es mehr franzosen als
deutsche geben stellen sie sich vor was
das bedeutet für das ihr match in 20
vielleicht 25 jahren wegen der
geburtenrate oder der einwanderung
nein das hat nichts mit der einwanderung
zu tun
frankreich hat viel weniger einwanderer
ist deutschland deutschland kann auf
einen ausgleich durch die einwanderung
hoffen aber das ist sehr schwierig und
in 20 bis 23 jahren wird es mehr
franzosen als deutsche gehen
das ist eine gewichtige georg
wie es übrigens auch wenn es weiter geht
der trainer als russen geben wird und
auf lange sicht wird es mehr nigerianer
als chinesen geben
sie sehen die welt bewegt sich und die
einwohnerzahl beeinflusst das
bruttoinlandprodukt
natürlich beeinflusst sich das
bruttoinlandsprodukt aber auch das
verteidigungs potenzial das steht im
verhältnis zum bip
davon hängt auch die renten sinken
die demografische entwicklung
deutschlands ist katastrophalen kommt in
bezug auf die geburtenrate in bezug auf
den arbeitsort auf die renten sicherheit
wenn sie die staatsschuld heute
geschuldeten renten zu bezahlen dann
reinigen sind eine schuld zusammenzählen
dann ist die deutsche schule viel größer
ist die französische sprache deutschland
heute so viel später die renten bezahlen
zu können
diskutieren sie darüber mit deutschen
intellektuellen daran sind wir uns
völlig einig es geht da um tiefgreifende
dinge warum hat frankreich seit den 40er
jahren eine bevölkerungs politik
betrieben hat frankreich hat begriffen
dass eine niederlage von 1940 mit den
demografischen gegebenheiten
zusammenhängen
eine frucht der politik der
zwischenkriegszeit deutschland wollte
keine bevölkerung die politik mehr
betreiben weil hitler eine solch
getrieben hatte
und wer familienpolitik sagt ruft ein
bild aus der schlimmsten zeit der
deutschen geschichte war
was natürlich absurd ist man kann
durchaus auch als demokrat eine
bevölkerungs politik betreibe ich ein
deutscher politiker würde ihnen wohl
entgegen
wir sind zwar weniger personen aber wir
haben die bessere wirtschaftspolitik
flexiblere strukturen frankreich ist da
unbeweglich und ich sage ihnen dazu
mehrere dinge das deutsche finanzsystem
ist katastrophal
sie haben keine großen banken und sind
der weltfinanz ausgeliefert wir haben
einige der größten und solidesten banken
europas wie sich gezeigt hat
es gibt keine großen deutschen banken
sparkassen sind keine großbank und die
deutsche bank ist praktisch keine
deutsche bank mehr sondern eine
englische nun zuerst hatten wir die
demographie seien die finanzen
drittens die energiepolitik deutschlands
erweist sich meiner meinung nach als
desaströs
infolge der entscheidung sie von der
kernkraft abzuwenden ist deutschland nun
von dem französischen atomstrom von der
polizei kohle und vom russischen gas das
ist eine äußerst anfällige
energieversorgung es gibt zurzeit kein
ersatz für die kernkraft und zu guter
letzt findet die industriellen
spezialisierung deutschlands nicht in
den richtigen situationen selbst wenn
wir annehmen dass sie recht haben und
ist für deutschland schlecht aussehen
ich wiederhole ich wünsche dass wenn wir
brauchen ein starkes deutschland mehr
aber all das ändert nichts daran dass
frankreich seine strukturen nicht zu
verändern
sie haben völlig recht nicht weil es
deutschland schlechte geht es frankreich
besser auf der demographischen ebene
geht es uns bestimmt sind und die
reformen man schafft es nicht einmal das
taxi wiesen zu rationieren das stimmt
ich bin geschockt darüber zu reden denn
ich habe zahlreiche reformen
vorgeschlagen gemacht wurden
es wird noch geschehen es geht um die
rede und das rentenalter das rentenalter
ist bereits erhöht es ist höher als
früher
warum fehlt in frankreich die nötige
dynamik um die dinge zu verändern
der wichtigste grund ist dass das
bewusstsein für die notwendigkeit
frankreich ist ein sehr reiches land in
einem reichen land empfindet man eine
notwendigkeit oder gar eine bedrohung
weniger stark zur zeit fühlt man sich
durch den terrorismus bedroht aber nicht
in bezug auf das wirtschaftliche
überleben wenn sie den reichtum pro kopf
der bevölkerung nehmen gehören wir zu
den reichsten der welt zusammen übrigens
mit den italienern die viel reicher sind
als die deutschen
das vermögen der franzosen ist viel
höher als jenes der deutschen ein
weiterer grund ist ein land reformiert
sich umso leichter je dezentralisiertes
ist weil da viele lokale experimente
möglich sind und wenn ein land dem meer
zugewandt ist nimmt es innovationen an
von außen das lässt sich nicht änderung
durch dezentralisierung frankreich ist
ein zentralstaat und gleich ist die
zweitgrößte see macht der welt ist
deshalb paris zu seiner hauptstadt
gemacht und ich fand immer eine große
tragödie frankreich sei das seiner
hauptstadt paris und nicht live ist ein
blick auf die weltgeschichte zeigt dass
die großmächte immer von hafenstädten
aus regiert wurden brücke venedig
general antwerpen amsterdam london new
york und heute shanghai tokio unter
weitere wir haben leider paris gewählt
ein land das einer hauptstadt im
landesinneren hat und eine starke
landwirtschaft besitzt ist ein land der
rente und nicht des profils sowie ein
land das lieber bewahrt als verändert
ein land in dem das neue einige vater
stellt ein land also das nicht durch
reformen voran kommt sondern durch die
revolution frankreich kommt man durch
revolution voran die revolution von 19
45 58 und ein achter und es wird in den
nächsten jahren eine neue folgen auf
irgend eine art eine richtige revolution
das volk auf den barrikaden oder eine
friedliche revolution der revolution von
1989 war friedlich sie bestand in einem
gewaltigen wandel man sieht schon sie
sagen das war eine revolution metering
brachte eine veränderung
das war eine gewaltige veränderung in
drei monaten gab es zahlreiche von es
braucht wieder eine solche es braucht
wieder eine solche schon bald oder hab
das noch zeigt das was leider geschehen
ist dieses attentat einen schock
ausgelöst
es hat aber in gewissen bereichen auch
die sensibilität geweckt und in dem maße
vielleicht für die fragen der
integration der jugendarbeitslosigkeit
des laizismus der permanenten bildung
und der deutschland ist nun weiter ist
als frankreich
hier können wir viel von deutschland
lernen
die duale bildung die berufsbildung es
entsteht ein bewusstsein das dauert noch
wenn ich sie so reden höre tönen sie
sehr optimistisch stützte wohl
reflektiert die theorie andererseits
habe ich gelesen dass waren glaube ich
sie der diese schreckliche vorstellung
geschworen hat dass man seit diesen
attentaten in frankreich auf eine
normalisierung zu gehen
schon vor jahren sagte ich dass das ist
eine vorstellung die ich vor zehn jahren
in einem meiner bücher gebessert habe
von so maly sierung spreche ich weil die
welt wie ich eingangs erklärte eine
marktwirtschaft ohne recht statt das
einzige land das 20 jahre lang einen
staat keine regierung hatte war somalia
und man konnte beobachten wie sich da
der drogenhandel und waffenhandel
ausbreiteten
eine illegale kriminelle wirtschaft die
welt von heute leicht somalia darum sage
ich die globalisierung ist auch eine
somali sierung des planeten
wenn wir nicht begreifen wie wichtig es
ist einen weltweiten rechtsstaat zu
schaffen gerade mir ins chaos
darin ist die schweiz ein interessantes
modell denn was wir auf weltebene tun
müssen ist die schaffung einer rechts
verfassung nicht durch eroberer format
von der erde noch durch einen chinesen
oder amerikaner sein imperium errichten
würde sondern von unten nach oben sich
eine übereinkunft der völker um einen
rechtsstaat herzustellen das einzige
lernen dass nicht durch einer oberer
entstanden ist sondern durch eine
vereinbarung mehrerer regionen kantone
ist die schweiz die eine nation geworden
ist in schätzungsweise 300 jahren seit
den frühesten bündnis das versuchen wir
in europa zu schaffen
wir versuchen einen europäischen staat
zu bilden aus dem zusammenschluss der
nationen
das wird man auch auf globaler ebene tun
müssen wenn sie vom rechtsstaat
sprechender garantiert die gesetze ich
kann einen richter anrufen
das
wir doch schon aber nicht auf globaler
ebene nein aber in europa sie fordern
ihr auch mehr sicherheit zb in
frankreich und überall wo solch
schreckliche attentate geschehen können
es gibt tatsächlich einen rechtsstaat
trotzdem verschwinden zwischen 10 und
maximal 25 prozent des bip eines jeden
landes deutschland in begriffe
nordeuropa inbegriffen in der
schattenwirtschaft der illegalen
kriminellen wirtschaft wir haben also
keineswegs einen perfekten rechtsstaat
auf der anderen seite sieht man dass die
eu glanz polizei nicht funktioniert dass
der datenaustausch zwischen den
flughäfen nicht klappt und dass es kein
übergreifendes justizwesen gibt braucht
es eine stärkere sicherheitsstruktur
demografie es braucht eine stärkere
demokratische struktur die sich unter
anderem auch unrechtsstaat stützt sowie
auf justiz polizei und gefängnisse und
die dem konzept der öffentlichen und
individuellen freiheit entspricht
die sich auf die demokratie das
europäische parlament und die nationalen
parlamente abstützt und die so weit wie
möglich integriert ist
es war ja viel davon die rede dass die
vorstädte namentlich jene von paris
rechtsfreie zonen sei das ist ein
zerrbild
ich leite eine große organisation die
sich planeten es nennt und in 80 ländern
jungen menschen hilft unternehmen zu
gründen und aus der armut herauszukommen
wir arbeiten auch in frankreich in
italien nicht in deutschland und in der
schweiz
wir arbeiten in den quartieren
wir haben da keine sie geben kredite
oder wie funktioniert das ja genauer
gesagt überlegen wir mit ihnen wie sich
eine idee finden lässt wir machen für
sie eine marktstudie ein businessplan
und anschließend suchen wir eine
finanzierung entwicklungszusammenarbeit
mitten in frankreich überall wir sind in
30 quartieren tätig da haben schon über
7.000 unternehmen gegründet
das entwickelt sich dann gemerkt es wird
das instrument präzise und sehr wirksam
und und es gibt keinen rechtsfreien raum
nicht jedoch die quartiere und trat ihm
überall wunderbare jungen menschen
natürlich gibt es auch gangster die man
manchmal als terroristen bezeichnet
aber in einer so sehr mediatisierten
gesellschaft wird der kleinste
zwischenfall für alle sichtbar und
schafft ein gefühl allgemeine
unsicherheit
doch die statistiken zeigen es gibt
heute auf die bevölkerung gerechnet
weniger droht durch gewalt als im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert und dieses zelte
weniger gewaltopfer als das jahrhundert
davor in wirklichkeit gibt es entgegen
der annahme einen rückgang der gewalt
aber wir sind ja nur mal so
mediatisierte ich muss freilich alles
jetzt gibt es diese tragödie mit 17
toten in frankreich und man hat von
einzelnen dieser 17 mehr gesprochen als
von allen zusammen das war symbolisch
von den journalisten und den
karikaturisten genau das waren teilweise
enge freunde und ich will auch gar nicht
kritisieren dass man sie betraut hat es
war eine schreckliche tragödie
aber man hätte auch von den anderen tue
ihm legen müssen und darüber hinaus der
mann von den 2000 toten reden müssen die
gleichentags bei überfällen in nigeria
gestorben sind
an diesem tag oder ein kleines mädchen
das von seiner mutter verkauft worden
war
als selbstmordattentäterin auf den markt
geschickt stellen sich diesen horror vor
aber davon war keine rede
wir leben in einer welt vielleicht
müssen wir das noch genauer analysieren
warum ging just vom tod der journalistin
die größte symbolische kraft aus weil
sie die journalisten der ganzen welt
betroffen fühlen
darum hat man darüber gesprochen werden
es 17 ingenieure oder lehrer oder
straßenkehrer gewesen hätte man weniger
darüber gesprochen spielte nicht auch
eine rolle dass es um die
meinungsfreiheit geht das ist eine
elegante zu sagen dass es um
journalisten geht aber in einer
demokratischen
gesellschaft das ist keine kritik
einerseits geht es zwar nicht um eine
erstrangige freiheit diese freiheit ist
fundamental ohne die die andern
freiheiten
es ist eine fundamentale freiheit
absolut erstrangig die übrigens im
gesetz umschrieben ist man darf nicht
alles sagen man darf nicht diffamieren
beleidigen es gibt grenzen die leute von
charlie hebdo wollten offenbar zeigen
dass es keine grenzen geben darf sie
akzeptiert mir keine grenze das hat auch
mit dem für mich zentralen thema von
vorhin zu tun der unterscheidung
zwischen nationalem und globalem recht
da ist dieses globale recht nicht liebt
wendet man das nationale an
in frankreich ist die vermehrung legal
in anderen ländern ist gotteslästerung
verboten
dort drohe wenn sie karikaturen im
internet haben und menschen diese in
einem land sehen wo gotteslästerung
verboten ist denken diese dass
diejenigen die diese zeichnung gemacht
haben etwas verbotenes getan haben dabei
ist es egal in dem land wo sie gemacht
wurden
das zeigt wie wichtig ein weltweite
radstadt wäre und eine gemeinsame
vorstellung von dem was legal oder
verboten ist
sie haben gesehen dass sie ein mann des
denkens wie auch ein mann des handelns
sind
was ist nun für sie das wichtigste für
unsere gesellschaften
ich fand in einem ihrer texte einen
interessanten gedankengang
sie sagten die entscheidung der
europäischen zentralbank habe etwas zu
tun mit dem was sich auf der terrorismus
ebene abspielt ja weil sie uns die
ressourcen gibt und den anstoß unser
schicksal in die eigenen hände zu nehmen
und uns besonders in europa instrumente
verschafft um nicht nur die banken zu
finanzieren was zwar nötig war sondern
eine gemeinsame verteidigung
wenn ich zum schluss nochmals auf ihre
anfänge in der
publik frankreich zu sprechen kommen
darf als sie präsidentenberater waren
ist die heutige lage nicht viel weniger
geld als sie es damals erhofft hatte sie
ist völlig anders und äußerst hilfe
sprechen denn die technischen
möglichkeiten sind faszinierend weil wir
eine viel bewusstere freiere jugend
haben ich bin sehr optimistisch mit wem
auch immer man derzeit über politik
spricht die anschläge von paris und
zumal die morde an menschen die als
karikaturisten nur mit der feder
gekämpft hatten sie beschäftigen uns
immer wieder und um weiter darüber zu
sprechen ob heute nicht mehr die
politiker die welt verändern müssen und
können sondern neben der wirtschaft
menschen die eben mit dem füller oder
mit kyle und feder in der hand kämpfen
haben wir auf ein wort patrick schappert
ins studio geladen den schweizer
karikaturisten von weltruf betrieb
schafft hat patrick sharp hat guten tag
jacques attali hat vorhin gesagt dass er
mit den meisten ermordeten
karikaturisten von charlie hebdo
befreundet ich nehme an sie als
berufskollege kannten auch viele von
ihnen
[Musik]
ich brauche diese sprache um mich
darüber auszudrücken
tatsächlich kann sich einige der
karikaturisten von charlie hebdo
personal bekannt waren sie mir alle wenn
es waren überragen den namen unter dem
presse zeichnen waren es idole für sie
hervorragende künstler kabul ins kies
und so etwas wie vorbilder für sie waren
nicht nur prägend für die presse zeigt
sondern auch für die freie
meinungsäußerung in frankreich nach der
68er bewegung
außerdem ist die welt der presse
zeichner kleinen herzlich moment richtig
so habe ich kabul und kinos kennen
die news war wenige jahre älter als ich
meine kinder er war ein wenig verträumt
sehr offen und warmherzig ein
wunderbarer zeichner
deshalb macht vor allem der menschliche
aspekt betroffen
17 menschen wurden umgebracht es sind
sehen die man aus gstadt ganze welt war
überrascht und beeindruckt von der
reaktion der belegschaft von charlie
hebdo die mit einer neuen ausgabe ihren
kampf mit humor fortsetzte video der
karikaturisten hat man sich also nicht
von der depression erfassen lassen
sondern wieder mut gefasst
kritik wird zu sagen wir alle sind tief
schockiert und erschüttert
es ist erst wenige tage her ich weiß
noch nicht wie ich das verarbeiten soll
seit zwei wochen spiel die welt verrückt
anruft und ständiges interviewen
gleichzeitig müssen wir zeichnen und
reisen von terminen zu sehen
deshalb bin ich auch hier in davos das
interesse ist enorm spontan möchte ich
sagen es wird sich nichts ändern
wir machen weiter wie zuvor wir haben
keine andere wahl
ob das die richtige reaktion ist weiß
ich nicht dazu ist es noch zu früh
sicher werden wir mit diesem schatten
weiterleben müssen eine grenze wurde
bestimmt etwas zutiefst tragischen jeder
reagiert persönlich darauf geht anders
nicht nur wir karikaturisten sondern
auch journalisten und andere menschen
der anschlag galt nicht nur den
karikaturisten sondern all jenen die
sich gedanken machen solche zeichnungen
anschauen und darüber lachen denkende
und schreiben es glücklich ist man als
zeichner isoliert oberwil die
karikaturisten eine gemeinschaft
es ist ein sehr einsamer beruf auch
innerhalb der journalismus
karikaturisten sind einzelgänger viele
zeichnen oft wie ich alleine matthäi
manchmal auch sehr weit weg ihr atelier
steht moment
den usa man kann also irgendwo arbeiten
aber der preis ist die einsamkeit
ja es ist sehr einsam und man sucht
allein nach ideen
diese isolation ist tatsächlich schwer
auszuhalten in einer redaktion in einem
team bekommen anregungen was wir machen
ist keine teamarbeit laufe eines jahres
gibt es nur wenige festivals oder
zusammenkünfte wo sich satiriker wie die
von charlie hebdo treffen oder zeichner
aus der ganzen welt oder aus arabischen
welt
man muss verstehen dass die welt für die
karikaturisten in den letzten jahren
anders geworden ist und zwar seit dem
dänischen mohammed-karikaturen 2005
da die gewalt in die welt der zeichner
ein
die ausgangslage hat sich verändert man
realisierte dass die presse zeichnung
dieser art ermöglichen darstellung zum
symbol für etwas viel größeres wurde
sie wurde zum brennpunkt eines konflikt
in dem sich die einen mit gewalt gehör
verschaffen
ein kampf der zivilisationen und
kulturen auf einer bildlichen
darstellung ausgefochten wird
wir sprechen hier von einer einfachen
zeichnungen auf papier etwas völlig
harmloses ja fast übliche bezeichnung
erinnert an unsere kindheit seit 2005
erwuchs daraus eine gewaltige religiöse
politische soziale und globale
herausforderung aber ein künstler wie
sie mir doch auch etwas bewirken ist es
nicht schlimmer nur witze zu machen die
keiner ernst eine deutsche zeitschrift
hat mich 2005 vor der ganzen geschichte
wegen der mohammed karikaturen in einem
ähnlichen umfeld wie hier in davos
interviewt und plötzlich kommt die frage
was ist ihrer ansicht nach heute die
größte herausforderung für die welt
seine phrasen kommt man nicht
aufgestellt ich antwortete aus dem bauch
heraus und sagte ich weiß nicht warum
einerseits leben wir in einer zunehmend
globalisierten
und er alles tituliert andererseits
schließen sich gewisse gesellschaften
immer mehr in ihre eigene welt ein und
der zusammenprall der beiden welten
gefährt zwei wochen später kam es dann
zu den protesten wegen der
mohammed-karikaturen
doch die zeitschrift hat meine antwort
gar nicht bedroht wäre sie eine woche
vor den vorfällen publiziert worden
hätte man nicht zum intelligentesten
mann der welt erklärt
denn so etwas wie das was ich gesagt
habe ist tatsächlich passiert
aufgrund von zeichnungen die nicht so
gemeint war man zeichnet immer vom
publikum etwas kulturelles eine
bezeichnung der nzz am sonntag ist nicht
unbedingt verständlich für leser einer
anderen konnte man richtet sich an eine
mikro kultur man zeichnet für ein
bestimmtes publikum erst einmal vor das
publikum des mediums für das man
arbeitet das zielpublikum und dann für
die bevölkerung des landes in dem man
nicht nur etwas kulturelles etwas
lokales die auch sitte und anstand oder
tabus und plötzlich durch das internet
werden zeichnungen von schuljungen
verbreitet die die richtig erwachsen
wurden die sich seit dem mai 68 nicht
verändert haben und sich im zug der
säkularisierung über jesus mohammed und
muss es lustig machen wobei es gar keine
geschlossene kultur vor allem notieren
sie sich über alle übermächtige und
dummköpfe auf der ganzen welt vor allem
in frankreich sie kennen keine grenzen
das ist die gewaltige herausforderung
die sie keine lösung für das problem
dass nicht alles dafür gemacht ist um
von allen verstanden zu werden
eine zeichnung von mir oder noch
schlimmer von charlie hebdo ist nicht
für einen afghanischen bauern gedacht
oder einen bewohner von äthiopien oder
pakistan
klar ich habe gelesen dass sie sich
engere grenzen setzen dass sie in ihren
zeichnungen nie bis zum äußersten gehen
[Musik]
das versuche ich auch wenn es andere
verletzt
nein erstens will die presse zeichnung
ist ab juni verletzten
das muss klargestellt werden denn so oft
höre ich leute sagen diese zeichnung ist
verletzend greift an oder signalisiert
der erst einmal dient die presse zeitung
dazu etwas zu kommentieren oder
anzuprangern
natürlich kann das in einen oder anderen
verletzten leider sind menschen schnell
einmal verletzt die empfindlichkeiten
nehmen zu es gibt immer mehr tabus immer
mehr gemeinschaften suche nach
anerkennung was ich verstehe aber zurück
zu ihrer frage ich arbeite nicht für
eine satirische zeitschrift mit shari
neben der definition die grenzen des
möglichen in unserer gesellschaft
auslotet die satiriker verteidigen die
freie meinungsäußerung in der literatur
in den bildenden künsten in der presse
auf ihre stimmen sind zb wir weiter
angewiesen damit wir heute wirklich
miteinander diskutieren
wir brauchen eine provokative welche die
freiheit verteidigen die absolut sein
muss was nicht heißt dass ich alle
zeichen von charlie du gut finde ich
aber auch auf die gleiche aufgabe
normalerweise arbeite ich für allgemeine
zeitung aber ein presse zeichner muss
die grenzen seines spielraums auslaufen
ich habe einen anderen spieler manchmal
auch die nzz auf grauen eine
konservative zeitung
und da sie es gut machen er ein zitat
aus ihrer sprache sellerie die kühl das
lächerliche kann töten
denken sie an die opfer wenn sie zum
beispiel einen bundesrat times korn
nehmen ich erinnere mich an bilder die
grausamer was andere aber nicht
ungerechtfertigt
so definiere ich dass das ist sehr
einfach mit papier und bleistift zu
verletzen
ich nehme ein blatt papier und zeichne
vor ihren augen etwas schreckliches es
ist einfach beleidigend provozierend und
gemein zu sagen aber das ist nie das
ziel das ziel ist vielmehr ins schwarze
zu treffen
das wieder gelingt das ist jedenfalls
meine erfahrung kann das sehr verletzend
sein
dessen bin ich mir bewusst aber wenn es
gerechtfertigt wenn man zutiefst etwas
überzeugt ist muss man es aussprechen in
die rolle des satirikers indes presse
zeichners ist es den finger auf die
wunde stelle zu lang
ich setze mir folgende rede wenn mich
jemand anlauf ein opfer meiner zeichnung
wie sie das nennen
jemand der sich dadurch verletzt fühlt
will ich dazu stehen können ich will
mich nicht wissen und sagen eigentlich
bin ich zu weit gegangen eigentlich
wollte ich das nicht sagen
vorhin habe ich mit jacques attali
darüber diskutiert ob die politiker die
welt noch verändern können
er meinte sie seien heute zu schwach
kann ihrer meinung nach ein zeichner
etwas ausrichten
ich denke eine zeichnung kann nicht mal
eine einzige meinen leuten dann ihr
wirkungsfeld ist zu klein
sie ist völlig harmlos doch nicht mehr
als ein paar striche auf einem blatt
papier
eine zeitung kann sie zum schmunzeln
bringen das ist ihre stärke
sie kann sie nachdenklich machen aber
wohl kaum ihre meinung ändern aber in
der zeichnung steckt eine große kraft
das haben wir erlebt und können es laut
sagen sie ist ein kommunikationsmittel
welcher auf das denken und intelligenz
eingelegt eine zeichnung trifft einen
bevor man sie begriffen hat diese kraft
des bildes sieht man durch all die
jahrhunderte seit den höhlenmenschen ist
ein unglaubliches mittel und kanals war
für eingesetzt werden
die zeichnungen kann eine waffe sein
der propaganda sie kann missbraucht
werden oder in falsche hände geraten das
zeigt die geschichte der nazis mit ihren
juden karikaturen oder die
mohammed-karikaturen 2005
man kann sagen die satiriker und ihre
zeichnung und wurden für den kampf
andere missbraucht und das wenn sie
erlauben beschäftigt mich seit zehn
jahren die aufgabe der presse zeichner
als unabhängige kritische künstler ist
vor allem die verteidigung der
meinungsfreiheit
die zeichnung darf sicher nicht zur
waffe werden in einem krieg oder wenn
kulturen aufeinanderprallen seine ganz
persönliche frage zum schluss wie sind
sie zu ihrem beruf gekommen wollten sie
das schon immer werden die presse
zeichnung ist ein seltsames wesen eine
mischung verschiedener interessen
ich las comics in der schule und in
meiner freizeit und ich interessierte
mich für die politik irgendwann verband
ich dann meine liebe für die zeichnung
meinem interesse an der politik
es ist ein nicht ganz übliche
kombination wird man damit glücklich sie
haben die einsamkeit ernennt suchen sie
längerfristig etwas weniger einsames es
ist ein wunderbarer ich werde dafür
bezahlt über das weltgeschehen zu äußern
und zu zeichnen
das schönste was ich mache aber nicht
nur das ich reagiere einerseits auf das
was geschieht aber ich befasse mich auch
grundsätzlich in dem zeichnen als
ausdrucksform und ich bekunde gern die
welt dies mache gemeinsam mit anderen
zeichnen reportage comics und projekte
in konfliktgebieten
die zeichnung ist ein werkzeug mit dem
man sehr viel machen kann vielleicht ist
das sogar die zukunft schon alles muss
wir haben also noch lang das vergnügen
zeichnungen von schabbat in unseren
zeitungen zu sehen darauf nächste woche
rede ich hier mit einer frau die
eigentlich im ruhestand sein und golf
spielen könnte es aber noch immer
vorzieht menschenrechts verbrecher und
mörder zu jagen ich rede mit carla del
ponte der ehemaligen uno chefanklägerin
für das ehemalige jugoslawien und für
rohren da sie kommt dann eben aus syrien
zurück aus syrien von dem sie sagt dort
sei die lage noch schlimmer als alles
was
sie früher in ihrer laufbahn gesehen hat
mit carla del ponte rede ich über das
böse jetzt aber zunächst einmal
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]